les griots touba un petit port mal fichu
au bout d'une île des philippines salle
dangereux fréquenté de contrebandiers
d'activistes terroristes bref
infréquentable exactement le genre de
débarcadère que choisit un gars comme
l'udc dénonce rembarquer en catimini son
matériel bouteilles de plongée par
dizaines zodiac soigneusement replier
moteur vivre puis vite quitté rio touba
l'infâme prendre la mer en toute
discrétion sans publicité première règle
de prudence à respecter quand on est
chasseur de trésors
quitte ici à 80 à 90 on va descendre
sud-sud pas la loi ni en garde caméraman
sur l' ave abord on descend comme ça
vers le sud on s'arrêtera probablement
du côté de caméraman et juste avec
l'huile de l'élu maire de bolbec
alors en route pour des îles grosses
comme des crottes de mouches leone sont
sournois des écueils
absent des cartes qui ont perdu tant de
navigateurs mais par où commencer
les indications viennent souvent des
pêcheurs directement enfin du moins ici
heures aux philippines il ya quelques
fois on tombe sur des intermédiaires
aussi qui viennent vendre des
informations
ils sont le quasiment à 99% et rené tour
des épaves qui n'ont jamais existé alors
au début quand la révision se fait ça
peut prendre au jeu pour aller voir
vérifier ce qu'ils racontent ans rend
compte que dans quasiment tous les cases
n'importe quoi qui est absolument rien
du tout ça fait un peu partie du jeu une
belle pièce remontée par hasard dans un
filet de pêcheur et c'est la rumeur qui
court dit loulou à l'ucl les v6 les
lanternes et les plus beaux monteur de
la mer de chine et de sulu réunit donc
là on l'a dit c'est tout un réseau aussi
aux philippines en c'est comme ça que
petit à petit on collecte des
informations
la formation qu'on essaie de recouper
pour voir si effectivement la porcelaine
qu'on nous emmenait vient bien d'un site
un site en mer parce que tout est
possible c'est peut être pour ce même
qui n incite à terre ça peut être un fou
qui ont été achetés au marché
tout est possible dans leur domaine
halte sur l'îlot de dali à cannes
pourquoi pour karim 86 cents anciens
commandeurs des forces rebelles
ranger des coups fourrés mais toujours
bien au sénat ça faisait longtemps qu
est ce qui arrive quand on y est pas
aidé
[Musique]
une écaille le salaire d'un vrai
maintenant je voulais te demander s'il
est bien vu des gens de pêcheurs qui
t'aurait par les départs sur lequel
tueur d or vous demandez une première
fois en anglais son détriment
puis recommencer en philippin avec les
formes russe de chasseurs c'est toujours
une histoire
nous voulons nous
ces tables aller de 1960 c'est les
américains qui veulent donner et russes
de gibier le coût de la table du grand
père traduction repasse me voir à
l'occasion
[Musique]
l'ifp il est ce assez bien bien au
travers de deux livres d'histoire on
entendu parler d'un bateau qu'on
recherche pas particulièrement et on
demande à l'archiviste de faire des
recherches sur ce bateau là ou bien
l'épave est proposée par un archiviste
qui ont souvent tendance à partir dans
une direction et puis on se rend compte
qu'en fait dire leurs intérêts sont pas
spécialement les mêmes les mêmes que les
nôtres donne ses 18 ans lui a dit moment
que son travail d'archivés d'archivés
les fans aimeraient bien retrouver le
bateau même si rien dans le bateau
jeunesse c'est sûr qu'il ya des épreuves
qui sera intéressante à à pouvoir
explorer mais qui au niveau valeur
commerciale n'ont absolument aucune
valeur uniquement une valeur
archéologique
ces trois citations
menant chez les rochers à fleur d'eau
c'était très intéressant aussi
légèrement à chacun son métier
je veux dire oui on peut pas faire
autrement il faut consulter les cartes
des manuscrits des journaux des procès
verbaux des cours martiales
correspondance diplomatique
attention cependant si l'ambassadeur des
consuls c'est un travail de fourmi
ça sera ni quand voilà une question
d'âge et d'analystes d'après l'unesco il
ya encore 4 4 millions des peuples qui
sont à découvrir au total dans dans le
monde entier sur eux sur toutes les
périodes 7,4 portugaise la bande de
travail a vu la distance entre mime à
makemo mieux
[Musique]
autant de projets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en février 2004 le couple onge pour la
première fois sur une épave à 58 mètres
de profondeur datant du 10e siècle
il est en train de découvrir l'un des
plus vieux navire commercial jamais
retrouvé avec à son bord cinq cent mille
pièces de porcelaine chinoise dont 250
milles en parfait état
formant un dôme de plus de six mètres de
haut une belle épaves les propriétés de
qui luc chasseurs ou pilleurs
payet tout une réglementation qui existe
à l'heure qui est le maquillage ou
pilleurs ici là parce qu'on a fait en
indonésie c'est tout
tout d'abord cette chinoise alors qui
est ce que ça appartient ce que ça
appartient à la chine appartient à
l'indonésie je crois que ça appartient
surtout sa part tient surtout à
l'histoire plus voilà terminé
[Musique]
je veux te dire que j'ai horreur pour
cela j'ai toujours fait ça chez les
grands mères dans le temps il ya
toujours des ascètes qui pendait selon
lui j'ai trouvé cette joute
non j'aime bien la table a pour cela que
j'aime bien ce surtout celles qu'on a
sorti non on l'a de masi parce que les
dessins sont très pur la glace entre
fini tout ça on est en train de chercher
ici l'eau des exemples ils m'ont voit
ses formes qui sont très très épuré
[Musique]
parlons chiffres entre ce que ça coûte
est ce que ça rapporte
donc je dirais qu'on est dans une
enveloppe aux alentours des 10 millions
de la faune ont été dépensés au total
les plus grands musées du monde envoient
leurs scientifiques expertise et cette
collection exceptionnelle des chiffres
délirants circulent 400 millions de
dollars
l'évaluation minimum de 45 mio et
normalement devrait être estimée plutôt
entre 60 entre 60 à 80 mio affolé par
ces chiffres le gouvernement indonésien
lance une information judiciaire pour
vol de patrimoine national au mépris de
tous les accords passés par lui qu'avec
les onze administrations du pays
la justice mais le trésor sous séquestre
jette en prison de plongeurs et bloque
la vente jusqu'à ce jour là tant de
façon incompréhensible parce que le
gouvernement indonésien a droit 50% de
l'avant donc certainement que ces gens
trop d'argent et que n'ont pas besoin de
l'argent qu'ils peuvent récupérer de
cette étape puisque ça fait quatre ans
qu'on attend les autorisations
maintenant dans ce pays qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire nous a posé plusieurs fois la
question pourquoi est ce que vous faites
ça de façon légale alors qu'il ya moyen
de le faire de façon illégale
mais c'est peut-être qu'il faut faire
dans ce projet
ou bien le faire en respectant une
éthique archéologiques ou bien alors on
est carrément pilleurs d'épaves ce
qu'est ce qui n'est pas le cas dans dans
pas ce qui n'est pas mon cas ce n'est
pas l'idée non plus d'un des partenaires
qui font partie de ces sociétés
m
résumons donc 10 millions de dépenses et
pas une seule soucoupe de vendu quatre
années de bras de fer sol contre un
archipel de mauvaise foi du luc
le chasseur éthique tient-t-il ses nerfs
eric tabarly plus de revenus dans votre
côte d'or qui est un petit peu plus de
20 mètres de long va mettre deux jeunes
femmes à 25 mètres c'est énorme on va
rejoindre une 14e vous connaissez bien
puisque c'est votre second qui a navigué
depuis toujours sur ce bateau est sûre
le kotor avec vous irrite cellucam ans
qui est belge d'origine la nationalité
alors lui comment se présente cette
cette compétition sur lorient saint
pierre et miquelon l'a vu que point de
vue vitesse on avait gagné beaucoup avec
les modifications à tout ça dans la
course aux la chose qu'on apprend
surtout ses dettes de nas pour arriver à
quelque chose et ça apprend aussi à d'un
autre côté à s'organiser pour monter
tout une opération pareille quand on
part pour faire un tour du monde il faut
il ou non plus quand on part pour faire
une opération de recherche de trésors
parce qu'on est là bas sans 200 milles
des côtes bateau devient on va pas pour
aller chercher la pièce conte oublié
aisément trois tours du monde avec un
set à paris
une demi-douzaine de transat autant de
transméditerranée l'admiral scop à
l'occasion quelques championnats du
monde maxi 20 ans de bourg landes
rien de moins comme équipier second
skipper voileux depuis l'âge de 11 ans
l'udc n'est pas un marin d'eau douce
même s'il vient du même pays que le
capitaine haddock
aujourd'hui armateurs du vasco anciens
faux chalutier russe et du sirène cargo
transformé en navire archéologique tout
de ancré dans la baie de puerto princesa
en attendant une prochaine expédition un
nouveau trésor
[Musique]
mais le chasseur de trésors chaque
humain mais un chasseur de trésors et
quand on est gosse tous les temps les
gosses ont envie de trouver un trésor à
un an à un moment ou un autre jeudi dans
le bac à sable est en train de creuser
parce qu'on retrouve 13e rang de son
groupe n'a pas apparemment chacun une
certaine dose de de deux chercheurs de
trésors et qui pour propres à alava
cimade luc aime tellement les épaves qui
l'a laissé couler un peu par goût un peu
par accident son précédent bateau dans
la baie de gouvernance entre deux
trésors
quoi de plus réjouissant que d'aller y
prélever une pompe hydraulique ou une
encre quant aux 500 milles porcelaine
chinoise
on entend dire que jakarta signerait un
permis de vente pour bientôt mais il ne
nous reste plus qu'à souhaiter à luc 60
millions de fois merde
[Musique]